i know there hasn't been an ask ig
episode in a while but i promise you
that this is an extra special episode so
keep watching
one of the biggest questions that i've
got this week is about the kanye west
taylor swift incident sometimes it's
hard for me to express my feelings so i
wrote a little song and it goes a little
something like this
i'm hearing what you're saying but i'm
so much
it's too late
so let me know what you think of my song
by the way in case you missed it i
actually hosted a twitter segment on the
vma pre-show so if you want to watch
that there's a link in the sidebar
i thought this was a pretty good twitter
question dannylv101 wants to see what i
looked like when i was a little baby
and then two seconds later ryan asked
the same exact thing so here we go
and it looks like not much has changed
has it
what's up buyer j it's garrett the actor
tv from youtube quick question what is
your favorite apple product out of all
the ones you've got
garrett did you really ask me what my
favorite apple product is the only
reason that i put your video in yours
because you had some really good editing
but come on seriously my favorite apple
product
i'll give you one guess yeah so ask ij
episode number 17 that's it over make
sure you guys leave me questions as
comments make video responses and ask me
questions on twitter and also i wanted a
shout out to pittsburgh magazine because
ah they put me on the cover this month
i'm so excited if you guys want to check
that out there's a link over there in
the sidebar or somewhere around here
where you can check it out
i'm excited okay that's all i've got
i'll see you guys later bye